let's go to our next caller from the 310  area code caller what's your name where  are you calling from and what coming for  you today XP corporate it builds  momentum people will see we affiant and  either this person is listening a  something else that's my voice is you  this is me yeah let's see if we can  figure out what the listener you  remember or con flash david pakman show  in last week if you ever shop on amazon  amazon com david packard.com slash hey  that's the message we can all get behind  go to patreon go to amazon okay well  anyway that caller very very interesting  clearly listening to to the show and  apparently too busy listening to the  show to actually participate in the show  gotta love it you got a lot of  absolutely